the jogan experience we are as a culture
being manipulated we're being
manipulated and it's moving us further
and further away
from just sanity just pure
sanity it's the foundations of of
Western logic right it's it's they're
they're trying to
poison the the roots of Western logic by
completely rewriting what what we would
call the history of the world and the
progression I around physics and math
and you name the thing that's under
assault it's under assault today and I
think who benefits from that you just
have to look around and say who benefits
from that oh our foes that's who
benefits from this I and not much has
changed if you think um now what 2 200
years ago we'll say Socrates was was put
to death for corrupting the the
corrupting the youth I think is what it
was and I'm like trying to recall it but
he was out there on the street arguing
and debating with people talking about
ideas and there the Athenians were like
we got to get rid of this guy he's he's
like he's pressure testing what we're
doing like we got to put this dude down
and uh and I think well that was 200
years ago so anytime the state deems
information is a threat we should
probably be looking at that information
and then really trying to like have an
open discussion about it that's the
beauty of America like freedom of speech
yes it is the beauty of America but it's
also why they're trying to crack down on
the internet right the internet has been
the biggest force in not just relaying
this propaganda but also fighting
against propaganda and let letting
people realize like hey like these
people that are supposed to be your
leaders they're compromised and they're
[__] you and there's some things that
they're doing now that they're just
doing and like what what is the economic
consequence of the hundreds of billions
of dollars that are being spent on these
wars that we're not in interested in
what are what are The Economic
Consequences where where are the actual
legal consequences for uh I mean here's
an easy one which is we invaded a
country of Iraq because of weapons of
mass destruction and they're that didn't
exist not one person went to jail we
spent more time trying to connect this
fiction around Russian collusion for two
years than we did investigating why
there was a massive information
operation internally to the United
States that said there was weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq not one person
went to jail not one person stepped in
front of Congress and with like had
depositions around why did you say that
there was weapons of mass destruction
when there wasn't not one person but we
spent how many trillions of dollars on
this war and how many people died yeah
how many innocent Iraqi died well I mean
these are hundreds of thousands of
people I mean my peir group alone just
thousands of people that are physically
and mentally altered forever that spent
uh you could you could you could say the
best years of our life in a war under
false
pretenses and now the long-term effects
are coming back and also the government
doesn't want to pay for that bill as
well so they they were trying to deny um
Gulf War syndrome remember that when
they were using depleted uranium rounds
mhm so these people were all getting
radiation poisoning and their their
children were born deformed and they
were having these massive problems and
they were trying to deny it because they
didn't want to pay for it they don't
want to pay for it they don't want to
write the check they do when it directly
benefits uh what I would say is the
military-industrial complex on these
wars of occupation I don't want to make
it sound like I'm anti I think there's a
there's a difference between a war of
necessity that maintains National
sovereign and a long-term war of choice
for occupation that's a a war of choice
and occupation is an exercise in
transference of wealth from the taxpayer
into the military-industrial complex and
that's like firsthand experience
spending uh 2003 to 2009 in Iraq uh I
mean that's that's a lot of time uh four
and a half years on the ground and then
another 3 years in
Afghanistan just seeing the expense from
blood and treasure alone over the course
of uh 10 years of deployments and
understanding what the difference is
between
Precision uh tracking and then killing
terrorists and what we needed to do in
order to stabilize a region and then
long-term massive Wars of occupation
there's a very distinct difference yeah
I think that's very important to bring
up and it's also very important to bring
up
that you have to have military power
because other countries have it m and
people who don't think that you should
support the military there's there's
people that think all military is evil
listen if we didn't have it what do you
think would happen what do you think
would happen like what do you think the
whole world would lay down their arms if
we did do you think that's what would
happen we have to live in reality and
the reality of this world and you know
it better than anybody this world is a
[__] messy place
it's we live in a bubble
here uh you know a very protected
artificial reality when you get out into
the most dangerous places in the world
that's where you
see nature that's where you see the the
real rules of life which is the only
rules are those of
physics bullets travel at X you know x
fet per second you have have a
collective team trying to organize
against in a in a very chaotic
environment trying to survive but really
you you strip every piece of what you
know around rules around what's right
and wrong your morality is put into
question your mortality is at stake all
the time and you see the real world it's
it's it's eye opening to the point of
you you
understand how great we have it in the
United States and how beautiful this
country is and you also understand how
fragile life is and how brutal the the
world can be and how brutal Humanity can
be towards each other you know it can be
gone like that
and I think being exposed to it for that
long and then coming home the the the uh
uh the things that I've been able to
pull away from that are this place is
amazing it's beautiful it's it's
something that we should foster and
encourage and continue to pass down
through generations because we're so
[__] fortunate to have hit the birth
Lottery being born here yeah like I roll
out of bed every day man I'm like this
this is [__] awesome like I'm so
happy to be alive like I'm so happy to
have all my fingers and toes and I'm so
happy for the experience of War because
it's shown
me what it's like
to understand my mortality sometimes
second to second but for sure day to day
for years on end and understand that
we're only here for a short amount of
time and we got to make it [__] count
and we also have to be very grateful and
gracious to what we have here for our
freedoms and our country and our
countrymen
and the experience of War itself that
chaotic environment that's shown
me traffic rules don't apply over there
right it's like traffic lights and
police officers and you know the things
that we take for granted every day going
to work you know making our coffee doing
all the things that we do you strip all
that away into just the law of nature it
is wild like it is forever lifechanging
but you also understand this is what
we're living in like these this is the
actual consequence of what we're living
in we we we're very protected in the way
that we live life right
now